aquí tengo descritas dos relaciones
diferentes entre xy y lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es encontrar si
estas relaciones son relaciones y
lineales exponenciales o ninguna de las
anteriores y como siempre los invito a
que pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolver esto por su cuenta
dejamos primero esta relación y la forma
principal para saber si estamos tratando
con una relación lineal o exponencial o
ninguna de las anteriores es ver que por
cada cambio en x en este caso pueden ver
que x se está incrementando tres
unidades cada vez se incrementa con la
misma cantidad en este caso 3 y dado que
estamos aumentando x con una cantidad
constante entonces nos preguntamos si
también si está incrementándose con una
cantidad constante si este es el caso
tendremos una relación lineal o si hay
una proporción constante para los
términos sucesivos en ye por cada
incremento constante en x y si este es
el caso entonces tendremos una relación
exponencial veamos aquí pasamos de menos
2 a 5 así que estamos incrementando en 7
esta cantidad cuando x aumenta 3 y
aumenta 7 y cuando x vuelve a
incrementarse en
y se incrementa en 7 así que aquí
claramente tenemos una relación lineal
incluso podrían graficar esto como una
línea incluso pueden pensar en la
pendiente de esa línea por cada cambio
en x de 3 tendremos un cambio en g de 7
así que nuestro cambio es constante
así que sin duda alguna esta es una
relación lineal ahora veamos esta otra
relación parece que nuestra x se está
incrementando en 1 en cada paso + 1
ahora cómo está cambiando nuestra y aquí
cambia en 2 luego cambia en 6 y después
cambia en 18 claramente esto no es
lineal si esto fuera una relación lineal
nuestro cambio sería con una cantidad
constante tendríamos el mismo cambio en
jr ya que nuestra y está cambiando la
misma cantidad cada vez ahora veamos si
esto es una relación exponencial si esto
es así para cada
cambio constante en x cada que
aumentamos x en una unidad nuestra
proporción de las 10 sucesivas deberá
ser el mismo en otras palabras con que
debemos multiplicar y si pasamos de 1 a
tuvimos que multiplicar esta cantidad
por 3 para pasar de 3 a 9 tuvimos que
multiplicar este 3 por 3 y para pasar de
9 a 27 tuvimos que multiplicar este 9 de
nuevo por 3 y en una situación en donde
cada que aumentamos nuestra x con una
cantidad constante en este caso 1 y las
10 correspondientes son multiplicadas
por la misma cantidad entonces tenemos
una relación exponencial
es lo que tenemos aquí